I mean now that we're here I'm thinking
about how much water I've gone through
just today let's get me hardshell so I
grew up pretty poor like I think I have
some idea of what it's like to not have
full access to things that I need water
is like a whole nother level though I'm
a little nervous to actually have to go
through that the only time I've really
not had running water is when I would go
to India as a kid we'd also have to have
boiled water because the actual tap
water or any other running water source
would affect us pretty badly we'd get
really sick and it's weird because it's
not even like to the actual degree that
people in Flint are going through
although I'm you know obviously really
down to do this part of me just feels
like a spoilt little [ __ ] still to be
honest because what I'm about to go
through is still just a tiny fraction of
what so many people around the world go
through every day my name is Joel
Epstein and I'm a los angeles-based
communication strategist and also a
lawyer and I've written extensively on
crimes against the environment and
efforts to clean up the environment
nationally some of our cities need to
upgrade their systems but there's a
reluctance on the part of the current
constituency the residents and
politicians to have the vision to make
the investment that's needed to be made
when Michigan is the classic example
when it was discovered that there were
very high levels of lead in the water
the residents of Flint are still
drinking and showering using bottled
water tremendous expense tremendous
environmental problem and it's really
just completely unacceptable water is a
right water is something that a citizen
should be able to expect from their
government so day one we're gonna use a
pump novel day two I'm gonna be
showering at the gym I go to day three
in and out of the shower with mouth
closed for I'm gonna use some baby wipes
day five boiling water and sponging
keep me going for a few days the pump
was a little tricky to use but I was
lucky enough to be able to afford that
pump I thought I had figured out how to
assemble it but I didn't because when I
started pouring water into it it went
everywhere I could not for the life of
me figure out how the [ __ ] to use the
pump and spray this doesn't feel very
self-explanatory I think I might just
dump a bottle of water on my head today
is day two I have my towel my mini soap
and all my clothes in my backpack and
today I'm going to be shivering at the
gym the gym was the best because you
know at least I have access to the
running water so I stayed in there for
like 15 minutes before I felt like I had
to leave so I just started doing the
dishes and I realized that I can't
actually rinse them because I can't send
the top on I just left my friend's
apartment after borrowing her shower and
it was fantastic it was also
uncomfortable to do all the things you
do in a bathroom which are kind of
intimate and private in someone else's
bathroom like you just feel naked and
afraid
so the packed bag with my towel and
toiletries
today I'm going to shower at work it's
not the first time so this shouldn't be
too odd but the thought of having to do
it every day would be pretty
uncomfortable I don't think I had any
issue asking for help once her friend I
could see how that would take a big
emotional toll relying on other people
to provide you running water yeah that
would suck I'm so thirsty day three we
jumped in and out of the shower really
quickly apparently that's a thing that
people do in this situation I ended up
just like cleaning myself with baby
wipes a day really I tried to take the
water droplets and like rub them on
myself with the towel and like scrub
myself with the towel I felt really
sticky after because like I still felt
the need to moisturize because I really
dry skin it's time for the operation
baby wax day 4 was probably the easiest
day to clean myself and like the least
emotionally totally baby wipes are great
I might do that more often wipe myself
down with scented baby wipes today not
the business they smell great they don't
do anything for you I probably used up
half the package I was just kind of like
scrubbing under my arms I'm not gonna
want this everywhere if you know what I
mean
the thing that gets me the most is on
drones after having to do this and they
after a couple days this still feels
like I'm lucky to have this
like a baby all day I did not use paper
plates at all but I also ended up
putting off washing my dishes because
it's so [ __ ] hard when you don't have
running water really the hottest part
was just the emotional strain of knowing
that this would be over in a week and
that there are hundreds of thousands of
people in the world you have to live
this every single day I became really
really aware of how much water I was
using I would never let water run down
the drain without thinking to myself
okay is there anything else I can rinse
off with this I noticed when it's
raining there's these repeat offender
homes and they all have their sprinklers
running while it's raining that's water
someone else in Flint or anywhere else
in the world where they don't get access
to water could be using but you're just
wasting it I feel like we don't fully
understand that until you kind of cut
yourself off from what you have you just
don't realize how bad it is for other
people I wasn't able to shower in the
morning so I showered at night with the
boiled water because it took so long to
cool and I had to boil so much of it to
actually use it it was definitely an
exercise in patience the head got down I
don't know how you could do any of this
with with wrong hair even short hair I
haven't washed my hair at all in the
past few days I've lived in really all
areas of the Middle East where we didn't
have running water or when we did it
wasn't clean that was only for a few
months at a time but to leave that
everyday to have a baby and to not be
able to bathe it or long hair that you
need to wash and it can't get in your
eyes or mouth every single day it was
easier than I expected in some ways and
also surprised me at how hard it was in
other ways I was able to connect a
little bit more to that situation
because you can read an article but it's
not the same as going through it we can
recreate not having running water but we
can't recreate the emotional experience
of being forced to not have running
water and not knowing when you're going
to get running water back what I got out
of this was it taught me how much of a
necessity running water is and that it's
not really something that can get ever
be up for debate the biggest thing about
this video is that this could easily
come across as poverty tourism I don't
want this to be seen as some
kind of voyeuristic entertainment from
other people's suffering it's more just
to get the word out there and to
hopefully showcase that it's ridiculous
that this is happening in developed
countries but it's ridiculous that it's
happening full-stop the least I can do
especially after doing this experiment
is make a little noise about it we all
kind of band together and like make it a
big deal maybe something will happen
faster because there'll be more tension
on it there is a lot of information out
there if you're willing to look for it
EPA is a good place to start the Natural
Resources Defense Council
it's another excellent organization
that's very focused on this earth
justice places like that being mad or
sad about any problem is obviously never
enough it's actually about standing up
and doing something and hopefully this
video gets that message across
[Music]